Ronni the limo drivers he burned out
Steph it's like Stephanie's vibrator
broke well I didn't really break it I
don't know what happened like lost its
power it wasn't given a good vibrate so
she had a call up Amazon and order no
one it's awesome
do I see I'll show you yeah it showed to
me really cool it's a little oh my
goodness now she likes that looks like a
little egg yeah so what do you do with
that like you did you put it inside of
her
or do you let me tell you this greatest
thing the whole jimmies listen possess a
great sex tip for him this is like a
real guys sex tip so like is his the
girl's [ __ ] right she pretend Mike no
face I know my fingers is a [ __ ] and
this little dildo that looks like a
bowling pin is my [ __ ] do you think I'm
sorry go ahead
okay I'll lay there with my head on my
pillow you know on my back and then
she'll lay down by when my dick is and
she puts one leg over my chest and one
leg is open the other way so like her
pussy's just about in my face but it's
not and she I could see everything she's
doing and meanwhile she's got the head
of my [ __ ] in her mouth it's great it's
the greatest [ __ ] thing it's like it's
Rudy [ __ ] has anyone having a better
time in quarantine that Ronnie I mean
Nessun to this
it's the city nine because in other
words Ronnie let me ask you something
bad you're describing the 69 position
well not it's not really the 69 position
because 69 position her ass would be in
my face and then she would be like you
know laying on my chest with her head on
my on my dick
what she does now she's like laying next
to me and she's got one leg over my
chest and one legs spread open on you
know like the bed okay and her head is
down by my penis could you draw that for
me Howard cuz I still can't see sure no
problem
do stick figures okay can you see this
Robin Wow I see I couldn't figure out
where everything was okay you go Ronny
puppet do you have it do I have that
right yeah that's pretty much it and
sometimes she's actually vacuuming at
the same time
you